should all schools in this country be
open this fall
for five day and five day a week in
person learning regardless
based on the science of the cdc they
should probably all be open
there's not overwhelming evidence
there's much of a transmission among
these people
young people he said probably he said
did not say absolutely because
we've all seen this since unfortunately
january of 2020.
it's an unpredictable virus it is a
virus that has you know it mutates
so we can't look in a crystal ball and
say what september looks like
well there's something about
going back to school and the impact of
the teachers unions
and there has been speculation about it
but this story about the
from the new york post with actual
language that the teachers unions gave
and
gave back and forth with the cdc has
changed the dynamics here and one
senator several are weighing in
the cdc is a thoroughly politicized
agency
most americans disregard their advice on
things like steaks and hamburgers and
beers
increasingly they should disregard their
advice when it comes to school
reopenings
we shouldn't have a politicized public
health bureaucracy like the cdc
answering at the beck and call of the
teachers unions we need
kids back in school and back in real
school not sitting in a classroom
doing a zoom session with teachers who
are not in the classroom
we need kids in schools with their
teachers
now so what about all this let's bring
in our panel byron york chief political
correspondent for the washington
examiner
marla lyonson national political
correspondent of national public radio
and trey gowdy former congressman from
south carolina uh
trey we saw earlier that the president
the first lady went into a classroom she
they asked how is this virtual school
going how was it
basically the answer they got was it it
really was horrible
yeah i think they used the word terrible
i think the lesson here brett is
follow the science unless a really large
political constituency that provides
lots of money to your election
tells you otherwise i mean if you're
going to follow the science follow the
science that says kids are being hurt
whether it's socialization nutrition you
name it they're being hurt
by being out of the classroom so look
they they sh
in south carolina my wife's the school
teacher brett she's been in the
classroom the entire year i find it
stunning that there are kids that are
still
not in the classroom mara there has been
this
push and then a walk back on the
terminology and these
these emails seem to show that there was
kind of a
couching of the words by the cdc or at
least they suggest that
yeah well it's unclear how much of the
cdc's guidance was
dictated by the teachers unions the
teachers unions are an important
constituency of the democratic party
they weighed in along with other groups
on these guidelines but you just heard
the president say that
school should be open and kids should be
in classrooms with
teachers and i think that's what you're
going to see certainly in september
if not sooner my kid just went back to
school and i'm really happy about it
sure and a lot of parents
who don't have kids going back to school
are very upset about but but then we
followed it up with anita dunn
who put the major couch on it saying he
said maybe or should
meaning they're not pushing for it yet
it doesn't seem
well they should because parents really
want it
yeah byron
well look we have been talking for a
long time about how the democratic
candidates
and then president biden were in the
pocket of the teachers union but i think
the new york
post story is really devastating because
it does show you
exactly how that works and one of the
worst parts about it is it is not
unusual in washington for lobbying
groups to suggest
language to government agencies i mean
it happens a lot of progressives think
it's a really
bad thing um but this is this is a
scientific
agency the cdc and basically what we saw
in the new york post report
was the actual cutting and pasting of
language from the teachers union
to cdc policy and then with anita dunn
you have a failure to say
affirmatively that schools will reopen
we
all know that if there's some terrible
resurgence and people are locked down
again and the disease comes roaring back
that would change things but right now
the government can say
schools will reopen in september i mean
just historical
here you look back to the cdc director
in which she said
that the transmission rate's very
minuscule and that kid should be able to
go back to school
even if not vaccinated or the teacher's
not vaccinated
then you had teachers in many places
across the country trey
that were first in line so that they
could go back to school
and yet many did not
i think you also have biden secretary of
education saying kids do better
in the classroom just like those kids
said in that video
what i do find a little bit interesting
brett is you know the the
the bite administration was talking
about forcing soldiers to be vaccinated
for the betterment of the country
i'm not telling you to force teachers to
be vacated how about just
encouraging them to get back in the
classroom how about say no to one of
your constituencies
i know he loves unions brett uh but but
he also is supposed to love kids too
just say no to the teachers union and
get the kids back in the classroom
you know mark anita dunn said we can't
look into a crystal ball
we don't know what september looks like
but they don't have that same
phrasing when talking about climate
change or the impacts
that need to happen now to change you
know how the country operates on that
front
yeah but they can operate with the best
science they have at the moment
and right now what the science says and
we've been told this by administration
officials over and over again
that it's safe to be in a classroom even
if a teacher isn't vaccinated
by last thing is i talked to brett about
this does this 1619 project
uh an education is it a big political
issue do you think
i i think it i think it could be i think
mitch mcconnell has been
absolutely right about this and the new
york times
intended the 1619 project to become
a school curriculum and this is
something that we
look there are debates about school
curriculum all the time
and the idea of reframing american
history to make
1619 the arrival of first africans who
became slaves
in what became the united states to make
that the country's quote
true founding that's the words of the
1619 project
of course you're going to have a lot of
people who do not want their children
taught that the founding was not 1776 it
wasn't when the constitution was created
it wasn't the federalist papers
it was about slavery i think there's a
lot of debate about that
yeah that story will continue for sure
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else